if the carwash workers can't organize
any workers can organize see sep 21 2015
10 straight errs including union leaders
and elected officials block traffic and
were arrested in front of a small car
wash in Brooklyn it was an empowering
moment these workers were willing to
stand out there to fight for their
rights and for a basic human dignity and
that's something that you take with you
for the rest of your life and you have
the ability to make change by coming
together and when you do that sometimes
you find that you've got some friends on
your side in the past six years
Industries like car washes that employ
low-skilled workers have been the target
of lawsuits for alleged under payment of
wages and they both engage in rampant
labor law violations an ambitious
unionization Drive
and a successful campaign to raise the
minimum wage in New York to $15 per hour
[Music]
but here's what really happened instead
of helping New York's low wage workers
the movement is destroying their jobs
it's pushed some car washes to replace
their employees with machines and others
to close down increasingly workers have
no choice but to ply their trade out of
illegal vans parked on the street
because the minimum wage has made it
illegal for anyone to hire them at the
going rate at the same time businesses
that have chosen to automate are
benefiting because outlawing cheap labor
makes it harder for new competitors to
undercut them on price and service this
is an in-depth look at the real-world
consequences when politicians interfere
with a complex industry that they don't
understand enabled by media coverage
that rarely questions their simplistic
tale of exploited workers in need of
protection protect I guess who protected
what are the king
[Music]
[Music]
in 2012 a coalition of progressive
groups led by the national retail
workers union launched an ambitious
campaign to transform New York City's
car wash industry the genesis of the
campaign came out of a realization that
you had an industry which was really
just a breeding ground for terrible
conditions hottest days of the year and
the coldest days of the year these
workers were outside working 60 70 hours
a week and sometimes more and not even
getting paid the minimum wage I think
workers felt that they didn't have many
choices and they really just had no one
that they could turn to and we felt that
we could have a real impact on on the
industry but the truth is that almost
from day one nothing about the carwash
campaign has gone as planned for
starters it turns out that most workers
don't want help from organized labor
after six years organizers have
unionized eleven businesses or about
four percent of the city's car washes
two of them have since closed down in
the Union withdrew at three more because
of a lack of support from the workers
there just six unionized shops remaining
or about two percent of the city's
registered car washes yellow being
equivalent to porta pero Yo Yo no tengo
beneficial Konami code a Delano Irvin
par is an immigrant from Guatemala who
works at Main Street car wash in Queens
one of the city's six remaining
unionized shops organizers have held two
strikes at this location in the past few
years and the New York Times has covered
allegations of worker mistreatment here
now Main Street could become the fourth
car wash where the workers pressure the
Union to withdraw the Mizpah Panero same
idea can no get in Massillon long young
protect them protect against who
protector what to the king
yeah me no me gusta trabajar aqui your
boy was pitamaha otro lado yo boy
I'm mucho look at it phallic llama have
longer say another la misma no ii of
macedon
at this particular time we represent the
workers there and we certainly hope that
we'll be able to continue to do that
with the unionization dr floundering the
movements leaders shifted their focus to
getting the city and state to mandate
change the most significant government
intervention championed by the union was
an increase in the minimum wage to $15
per hour
[Music]
this move is up ending the industry but
not in the way activists intended we've
heard over the years from employers
repeatedly that any time that we've made
changes within the industry that either
they'd all automate or the industry
would suffer massive shutdowns we
haven't seen that happen today in
reality that's exactly what's happening
the $15 minimum wage is driving many new
york car washes to replace men with
machines such as at this large operation
in queens that installed a new arch for
hosing down vehicles which will replace
about four workers like many of the
city's car washes this one was designed
at a time when manual labor costs less
than installing and maintaining
machinery labor was cheap
yeah real cheap Ahmir Malky is a
second-generation car wash builder when
he started in the industry in the 1980s
operators all over the city were
actually dismantling machinery because
rag hose and brush willing men did a
better job for less today
it's reversing labor is expensive i we
need the proper equipment to clean so we
don't have to use extra men it's not
just renovations new fully automated car
washes are opening up such as this
state-of-the-art outfit and you're j
keh airport with electronic gates a
self-serve vacuum and a single manager
on site making sure everything is
running smoothly
carwash owners are choosing to automate
even though it entails substantial risk
take best auto spa in Brooklyn one of
the city's premier hand washes drawing
clients who care deeply about the
appearance of their cars and are willing
to pay more for the human touch the $15
minimum wage means that this business
model is simply no longer viable
so best auto spas transforming from the
equivalent of an artisanal Bistro to
becoming just another fast-food joint
two years ago the owner installed
$200,000 worth of equipment which
allowed him to layoff eight workers now
he's facing another policy change that
would further increase his labor costs
employers are currently allowed to
attribute a portion of the tips earned
by their workers towards meeting the
minimum wage requirement New York State
is seriously considering a proposal to
eliminate the so called tip credit if
that happens come January the owner of
Vegas Auto Spa says he'll have no choice
but to give all these employees a pink
slip and go fully automated then you
have mmm wunderbar Church Avenue you
have new fully automated places opening
up like City Car Wash Express on
Northern Boulevard and Staten Island I
could go on what is your take on these
examples which I think do actually show
a major trend towards automation I get
it if you go into a car wash and an
owner is said i've automated because of
what's going on here that it makes you
think that it's like you know part of a
much broader story I'm not saying it
isn't the case I'm just saying that it's
like that might not necessarily be the
case it's true that not every carwash
owner is willing to take on the risk and
expense of automation and there's
another option exit the business and
relinquish their land for more
profitable uses which has also been
happening at many New York car washes
several car washes have closed after
their owners were sued for paying off
the books and not complying with labor
regulations we will continue to keep an
eye on these businesses to ensure that
they don't stray from the path of
righteousness practices a lawsuit
contributed to the closing of this car
wash in Woodside Queens to this one in
Harlem
and to this one in Upper Manhattan at
each of these locations dozens of
low-wage jobs disappeared our workers
really better off when the car wash that
they work for it closes now yeah I don't
agree with your assessment that these
car washes are closing as a result of
wage and hour lawsuits
that's that might not necessarily be the
case I may be how its being
characterized to you another unintended
consequence is that for business owners
who choose to stick it out and automate
the $15 minimum wage actually protects
them from competition by making it
harder for new car washes to open up
solely from being a businessman the
increase in the minimum wage makes my
business so much easier the best thing
that could happen to me and I think to
the industry Jack Gilinsky is the
manager of a new car wash in Queens it
opened last year at the site of yet
another labor heavy operation that
closed following a wage in our lawsuit
the new owner converted it to a fully
automated exterior only car wash meaning
customers are left to vacuum the
interiors of their own vehicles because
we used to do the same thing with 25
people now I'm doing it with two by
making cheap labor illegal the $15
minimum wage made it possible for
Belinsky to downgrade his service before
if I go exterior and my competition says
he went exterior I'm still free service
I'll take all his customers that never
gave me a chance to go exterior right
now everybody's forced to go exterior
because of this crazy law and the
minimum wage $15 an hour now everybody
if even though the field the $15 minimum
wage amounts to government prohibition
of low wage work and yet just making
something illegal won't stop able-bodied
men with few alternatives from meeting a
market demand for their services
they live in the shadows the irony is
that progressives have pushed car wash
workers further into the shadows since
legitimate car washes can no longer hire
them workers are going to the streets
where it's all cash no taxes no unions
no workers
no insurance and certainly no wage
floors aleko me on all you other people
showing up they make it ever hot now on
the quarter note ID Fausto who asked to
be identified by his first name only is
an illegal carwash worker he's part of a
three-man operation washing cars on the
curb out of a van for about fifteen
dollars a pop la la guitarra marginal
upon us you know lucky talk what I know
today was he's lived in the US for 19
years and still sends a portion of his
earnings back to the Dominican Republic
to help support his wife and children
how the hell can you how can I compete
because of these guys they're paying
they're paying cash you understand
they're not paying the proper tax is
fika uninsured but I am
and now the established car washes left
with no choice between stall expensive
machines and plaster their walls with
operating licenses are the ones
clamoring for the government to enforce
the minimum wage we worry for the
workers look at the rules that we make
but if those rules are not enforced
those laws are toothless they only
destroy the good guy that tries to
follow of all the rules and has to
compete with the bad guy that breaks all
the rules no tiara bahara Toshio neutral
hockey mask Yo no puedo encontrar classy
some of these guys working out of these
vans don't have other employment options
are you sure that it would be in their
best interests to shut them down yeah I
I actually I I do and I'm gonna be very
blunt about that you can always make the
argument that you can allow some people
to skirt the law some people discourage
that are meant to protect workers in an
effort to give people work opportunities
that's a devil's bargain or maybe the
real devil's bargain is championing a
set of policies that sound good at a
rally but that in the real world
jeopardized the livelihoods of the
working poor which brings us back to
Vegas Auto Spa the Brooklyn Car Wash the
progressive activists made an example of
back in 2015
shortly after the car wash unionized the
owner started planning his exit strategy
two years later he found a buyer who
kept it running for one more year
today Vegas Auto spas shuttered and the
ripple effects of the entire movement
have been to destabilize an industry
pushing the men and women who worked in
it even deeper into the shadows
you
[Music]